hi there
day 40
fighting the flu
and today i'm going to talk about
what you do when you don't feel like
studying
because excuse me today was such a day
i watched the um
canada sweden final in the olympics by
the way i should say that uh if there's
only russians watching out there i think
that uh
sochi was a great job was a great
success spectacular scenery of those
mountains
the facilities were amazing the hockey
rink with the uh the flags of the two
countries on the outside the score
all everything was was uh first class
and everything that i've heard suggested
was
um journalists are always going to pick
on things to make a make a story you
know
about this didn't work or that didn't
work we had the same in vancouver
but overall there were lots of doubts as
to whether russia could pull it off
building uh you know basically a whole
olympic facility where there was nothing
and
basically russia russia did it the
opening and closing ceremonies were
spectacular featuring
russian culture music history and so
forth was a great uh
it was a great event congratulations
and of course i'm very happy that canada
won the hockey gold uh it would have
been nicer to see russia and canada in
the final
but uh there you go
today i didn't feel like studying what
do you do when you don't feel like
studying it was two o'clock before i
even and it's a sunday here
before i even considered studying i had
the 15 minutes with julian on
on skype i spoke uh an hour of russian
half an hour with evgeny in st
petersburg half an hour with uh elena in
uh near near kiev in the ukraine
uh because i'm following this uh the
situation but i just couldn't get myself
to study so what do you do
the key thing in language learning is
time you have to spend the time
so
when
you don't feel like
studying find something that you feel
like doing so i didn't want to sit and
link at my computer um
i didn't really want to go and do my
ipad thing so i said hi
i'll go and look at all the books that
i've bought in the past
when i studied
korean seven years ago
and see if there's any anything there
that i can be sit and do and get myself
to do so
uh there was this book from japanese
which i sort of started thumbing through
but it was just the typical you know
boring
dialogue how are you it's cold you know
blah blah blah so um
i could
five minutes i gave up on that
then i went to this other reader that i
bought some years ago and i did two or
three chapters in it but it's just too
boring it's
you know festivals in in korea and uh
folk tales and things of that nature and
i just couldn't so but i did
now i put in 15 minutes so i'm getting
there
i looked at some of this series here
that i had bought and it was deadly as
well
so and this one here was deadly so i
wasn't getting very far
so then i started i did some reading of
my dictionary this is an excellent
dictionary by the way
excellent because if what i'm reading is
boring anyway which is the case with
those materials
this here they have example sentences
for each word
someone has two
and they have the translation which is
handy if you don't know the meaning
and
it's kind of you know i always talk
about the big picture the nuts and bolts
so here it's an opportunity to go after
the nuts and bolts and i was able to do
it for a short while so pretty soon i'd
gotten in about half an hour three
quarters of an hour
getting tired of that
spent a little time on my
japanese grammar book i was able that
for a while
and finally i sat down and did you know
with my uh
now it's gone off here
with my uh you know my ipad here's this
it's a story i have the sound i can look
up the words i don't know
it's an 18 minute long
economics article that one of our
members loaded so i did that for about
an hour so i guess i'm up to about an
hour and a half today and if i persevere
although my wife is saying we're going
to watch downton abbey tonight so
tonight might be a
a light day but the point i wanted to
make is when you don't feel like
studying vary it try to find something
you can do
if you're tired of doing this then do
something else listen
try to get that time in i think some
days are going to be lighter like i'm
saying
normally i'm i aim for an hour a day
with listening mostly listening here
with my challenge i'm trying to force
myself to get to that three hour a day
thing but i think today is going to be a
little bit light
so
there you have it i think if that's why
i you know
maybe i buy a lot of books i'm obviously
i spend most of my time on link i love
using link i developed link because i
felt the books
had a number of disadvantages compared
to what the internet can provide now
with mobile apps even more so
but i also buy books because you need
that variety
when i was doing romanian i downloaded
this tremendous
grammar
collection from the internet which had
hundreds of examples and i'd spent some
time with that
uh you know and it's it's all printed
out so i even sit in the bathtub and i i
do that for a while and
and uh listen so if you can have a
variety of things that you can do even
covering the same material
uh so that when you don't feel like
doing anything of all of 10 different
options maybe you might find one that
you can spend 15 or 20 minutes at
something else that you can spend some
time at and
put in that time you got to put in the
time so that's all i have to say when
you don't feel like studying find a way
to do something
or in the worst case take it